civil rights attorney Ben Crump is with
us now he knew Cummings for a decade and
considers him a mentor and a role model
good to see you Ben Crump today these
circumstances I'm sorry to say but what
can you tell us about him you know we
just heard Nancy say that the grief on
Capitol Hill was bipartisan what can you
tell us about him Gail Elijah Cummings
was a prince of a man he was a giant in
government but more importantly he was a
pillar to our community
I remember when Trayvon Martin was
killed he was co-chair and the
Congressional Black Caucus panel on
black men and boys and how they are
disproportionately a fact that em by
profiling and unemployment and he
they're here and made the preamble to
the Declaration of Independence real we
all are created equally and you saw that
with him and our government the US
Congress talking about this black child
who had been taken away from us and then
I remember Gail Debbie wasserman-schultz
yes congresswoman in South Florida was
going through a real Asian bed and we
had a host at congressman Cummings to
come down to South Florida and we for 48
hours campaigned and it was excited
because I'm sending morning we went to
all the Baptist churches and the black
community received him in awe but then
we went to the Jewish synagogue and it
was the same reaction respect on both
sides of the aisle and across
communities absolutely he was so
dignified as a past president of the
national Bar Association he was a black
attorney so he meant at all this young
lawyers and told us about diplomacy and
trying to have conflict resolution and
not being disagreeable even though you
disagreed and I think we saw that play
out in the halls the highest levels of
our government with Elijah Cummings just
a terrible loss mr. venema surprised and
shocked does everyone else when we got
up to the news thank you thank you very
much you were here to talk about your
book it just it just worked out that
you're here in the same day that he
passed
away so he will be back then crumpled
join us again in the next half hour to
discuss his new book it's called open
season legalized genocide of color
people that's ahead on CBS this morning